a Mac Marlon Brando's stars in the 1954
movie on the waterfront is a dockworker
who turned against corruption 64 years
later the agency created to clean up
organized crime on the real waterfront
is fighting to survive the Port of New
York and New Jersey processes nearly 7
million cargo containers a year
delivering more than 200 billion dollars
in goods across America New Jersey
recently passed a law to close the
waterfront Commission of New York Harbor
an a historic anti-corruption force Tony
de copal visited the port where
regulators say the influence of the mob
hasn't changed it's already the busiest
port on the East Coast and now the
cranes and docks of New York Harbor are
poised to get even busier as giant new
ships arrive from around the world but
this modern waterfront still hasn't
shaken its criminal past according to
the watchdog group responsible for
fighting organized crime on the docks I
like to say if you watch on the
waterfront not much has changed except
the waterfront snail in color
Walter Arsenault is executive director
of the waterfront Commission of New York
Harbor a special bi-state agency created
in 1953 to fight the type of
institutional corruption that was
prevalent back when his grandfather
worked here New York is blessed if
that's the right word in quotes with
five organized crime families all of
those families in some way are connected
to the port absolutely as a choke point
in the global economy the port has
historically been exploited by criminals
who forced payoffs and other kickbacks
by controlling who unloads the ships and
how quickly that's still the case as
Arsenal the crazy thing about the
waterfront is you tell people about it
and they look at you and say now that
can't be true there's no way that's true
his organization has identified some
four hundred longshoremen getting
special deals from the shipping
companies worth a hundred and seventeen
million a year some for work they rarely
do there are people who under the
agreement are getting paid 24 hours a
day 27 hours a day because because they
miss meals allegedly they get
an hour meal credit for breakfast lunch
and dinner so they're actually paid 27
hours a day 365 days a year longshoremen
Paul Moe held one such job earning four
hundred and ninety-three thousand a year
until he was convicted of fraud and
sentenced to federal prison in March he
collected his weekly salary when he was
in Aruba he collected his weekly salary
when he was in Florida he collected his
salary when he was at the movies when he
was with his girlfriend he collected his
salary
mostly when he wasn't there the
Commission says these special jobs are
almost always filled with favorite
individuals and connected to union
leaders or organized crime they also
increased the cost of everything from
coffee to cars who pays those costs the
consumers it gets passed on to the
consumers we're talking about tens of
millions easily you grew up right here
yeah former New Jersey State Senator ray
Lesniak led the effort to shut down the
Commission they sound like the good guys
they do sound like the good guys but
they're not why because they are
corrupting the legitimate business
practices and trying to interfere with
them that's on American Lesniak father
became a longshoreman before they had
the protections of organized labor which
he says the Commission now threatens
they're trying to break the union
the unions have made America strong my
dad didn't get the benefits because he
didn't have a strong Union you do not
need to break the back of labor unions
in order to drive out corruption
anywhere Lesniak wants to transfer the
waterfront Commission's responsibilities
to the New Jersey State Police I want
the money that's the going to the
waterfront Commission twelve million
dollars yet to go to the New Jersey
attorney general's office where they
have better tools to do what the
waterfront Commission is doing without
interfering with the legitimate business
practices hello is it legitimate for
somebody to not show up at work and be
paid twenty four or even twenty four
seven hours a day it's totally wrong all
right what are you gonna do how are you
gonna stop that that other waterfront
Commission oh it's a mission no it's not
they have no authority over the labor
agreement that's between the terminal
operators the stripping them see that's
the problem
Lesniak says this is a labor issue not a
criminal issue
Eddie respondent our enabling statute is
to end corrupt hiring practices and I
can't think of a more corrupt hiring
practice than discriminatory hiring over
the past year the waterfront Commission
has revoked denied or forced the
withdrawal of work applications from
people associated with all five of New
York's notorious crime families are you
worried taking this on No why not I've
been a prosecutor in my past life when I
was at the Department of Investigation I
did political corruption and organized
crime when I was at the Manhattan DA's
office I specialized in violent drug
gangs
it's what I do now we reached out to the
organization's representing the dock
workers and the shipping companies both
declined to comment so did the largest
terminal operators now as for that bill
that would do away with the waterfront
commission that passed the New Jersey
Legislature nearly unanimously but was
recently blocked by a federal judge Nora
all right Tony thank you doing some
great reporting out there raising a lot
of important questions
hmm